good morning John serve good news and
our bedrooms actually have lots of good
news and a little bit of bad news and
the first bit of good news is that I did
the bad news in my last video so if you
want a bad news go out of that video on
to more good news
George Watsky I accept your challenge
that wasn't intended to be a challenge I
be the one that by the vote I said about
a bet it could have been a bit of man I
want to be Sam but I've a sipping on
some medicine instead of meditating but
again and when I can I don't want to
wind up in the gutter with a bottle of
malt like a bitter cuz I never got a
call telling me that it's all figured
out we stick it out but I'm looking at
the wall plotted me was hoping to be
caught up in the good in the gotta me
but I got at the bottom you gotta get
that oughta be kind of day I fail your
challenge you don't know what I'm
talking about you should click more good
news if you would please go to this
website I know I've called google.com
and in google.com type is space H I'm
freaking awesome and then if you type in
is Hank green space you get a ton of
amazing things that people are wondering
whether I am including if I'm gay
unfortunately that one somehow slipped
in but people are also curious if I'm
Batman so I figure I'll take these off
and I'll put this on ah so what do you
think Batman no not really
no you're not not seeing it maybe I
should talk like this more good news
this map shown here is an extremely
detailed view of the 12 colonies of
Battlestar Galactica and how they can
all exist within one star system it's
possible because it is a quaternary star
system to binary star systems orbiting
each other that's an 8 ah the mysteries
that our galaxy must contain you should
make a video about the James Webb Space
Telescope which is going to help us know
more and it's awesome and amazing oh
this obvious desire at the beginning of
Battlestar Galactica for it to be hard
science fiction really makes me feel
even more disappointed by the stupid
ending to that series geez I have to go
to the doctor now so so let's talk about
this app that at the doctor's office so
science fiction and fantasy take up the
same space in the book store and they
take up the same space on my bookshelf
so I do agree that they have many things
in common but I have a very specific
rule when it comes to science fiction
and fantasy if you as a writer are
introducing me to a fantasy world and
you are free to define that world in
whatever way that you choose and to
solve internal conflict in whatever way
you see fit but if you're introducing me
to a science fiction story where the
reality of the book is based on the
reality of reality you cannot this is a
law you cannot solve the internal
conflict with
made up glowy holes in the ground like
they did in lost in short fantasy can
contain science fiction science fiction
cannot contain fantasy it's boring in
here more good news a pre so which is a
manageable facsimile of a circle the
drug that I need to take the cost $600
now just sent me this card in the mail
that says I pay no more than $25 for
Maya preso except unless I have to pay
more than $75 which I do because it's
like $200 so this is a lie but it's
still less than $600 why does it say pay
no more than $25 when I still have to
pay like 150 that's more than $25 that
is a bugger of an asterisk right there
more good news today we are officially
launching VidCon and some of you will
find that laughable because people found
our website a long time ago but it is
officially online now VidCon 2011
dot-com is in Los Angeles at the same
hotel that it was at last year at Hyatt
Regency Century Plaza July 28 Thursday
is going to be an industry-specific day
and then the 29th and 30th Friday and
said are gonna be freaking amazing fun
party adventure community time frickin
amazing fun party adventure community
times what what could you ask for and to
register for the conference and find out
all the information that you need go to
VidCon 2011 dot-com ok now the final
piece of good news is for the people who
follow me on Twitter and are very
curious about the two truths and a lie
that I did yesterday that I did not
inform them which one the lie was so two
truths and a lie one I just found my
first gray hair - I used to play the
trombone in high school or three I'm a
closet Allen Jackson fan click down here
to find out if you are wrong John I will
see you tomorrow